bah oui alors dernière chance d'être
d'accord ce sujet un peu plus léger ce
soir c'est une affaire qui a débuté le
14 février ce jour là le conseil
départemental de haute-garonne monde est
une entreprise spécialisée pour
descendre de la neige du céciré
jusqu'aux pistes cure enfants de luchon
superbagnères et le tout par par
hélicoptère cinquantaine 50 tonnes
pardon de neige transporté pour 5 à 6000
euros en espérant un rendement 10 fois
supérieure alors pas super écolo a
reconnu le conseil départemental mais
nécessaire disait-il alors aujourd'hui
cet après midi en ce moment les
responsables syndicalistes qui sont
reçues c'est elisabeth bornes on écoute
leur défense qu'est ce qu'on a fait à
luchon nous avons mis de la neige moins
de 50 mètres cubes sur le remonte pente
des enfants pour qu'ils aient la
possibilité d'avoir des cours par les
moniteurs de ski le land de même j'ai eu
le dilemme de dire ok et je les fais et
je les fais pourquoi parce que je
protège l'emploi parce que nous avons un
appareil économique sur les montagnes
qu'il faut certes faire muter et qu'il
faut conserver ces emplois ou l'écologie
l'histoire des choses si ce monsieur a
dit vrai bon je trouve ça plutôt
sympathique d'avoir couvert la [ __ ] en
forme et c'est ce qui est intéressant
dans l'histoire de chaussée pas
l'histoire du chant c'est ce que celle
lice la problématique des stations de
ski aujourd'hui alors du réchauffement
climatique a bien sûr en suisse par
exemple les banques ne prêtent plus aux
stations en dessous de 13 100 m pour
yport pour financer leurs équipements
en fait en gros on voit qu'à deux
stratégies dans les stations de ski une
très majoritaire qui est courage fuyons
serre on se dit c'est la course
technologique son visa trois quatre ans
on peut on peut car encore être gagner
du temps et la contactologie elle est
possible par exemple les canons à neige
c'était quelqu'un m'explique à saint
ludger les canons à neige qui autrefois
ait besoin de zéro degré pour que la
neige tienne aujourd'hui arrive à
fonctionner que la moins quatre donc bon
peut-être pousser un peu les limites
c'est après tout faire du ski sous bulle
comme à dubaï donc il ya une possibilité
de faire sa course aux investissements
et puis une autre fraction de
deux stations totalement minoritaires
qui disent bon a de toute façon ces
fichiers à 25 ans dans la limite pluie
neige s'abat cédera donc il faut se
reconvertir faut investir dans des spas
dans des activités tête et c'est parce
que est en réalité ce qui se passe aussi
comme problème c'est que même même
celles qui font cette course la course
technologique ont dit que ça risque de
pas marcher vraiment parce que - yann
neige
moi ya des gens qui apprennent à ce qui
est par exemple en italie on pense que
les stations sont données à très court
terme donc ça veut dire qu'ils y tenait
non plus à prendre à ce qu'est donc
toute façon bien plus de clientèle donc
je trouve ça intéressant problème
textuellement bon c'est pas mal que pose
cette question mais c'est vrai qu'à la
nostalgie parce que la neige c'est aussi
tout un ensemble de sa vitaliser d'état
d'état de région enfin c'est vrai que
c'est dur d'y renoncer je les comprends
à luçon nous a fait remarquer que
c'était pour la piste de ski
désinformées oui il a dit maxime n'a
gagné cette saison punitif l'écologie ou
est-ce que c'est punitif faut punir les
enfants qui veulent skier
je ne sais pas après vous allez croire
que j'ai des obsessions mais pour le
coup ce qui m'a choquée moi puisque
c'est la question c'est d'ailleurs je
trouve qu'effectivement ça sert à rien
de pointe et le conseil départemental
dans cette affaire parce qu'ils
expliquent leurs difficultés
par contre avoir la secrétaire d'état en
charge qui fait un tweet pour dire c'est
un scandale il faut changer de modèle
mais j'ai ouï c'est son boulot c'est
dire que moi ce qui me stupéfait
aujourd'hui c'est qu'effectivement il ya
des choses irrationnelles aujourd'hui et
qu'ils peuvent
moi je crois à choquer beaucoup de monde
c'est que vous avez un discours
justin que je partage qui est de dire
qu'on a le réchauffement climatique et
donc il faut faire attention
ils comprennent notre environnement et
vous avez des petites stations qui sont
obligés d'avoir recours à un hélicoptère
vous avez de l'autre côté pour prendre
quelque chose que je connais bien qui
est on nous explique qu'il faut arrêter
et on a raison de le faire les
transports par camion et par voiture
eh bien on supprime le train des
primeurs entre rungis et et perpignan et
donc il ya une espèce de contradiction
absolue aujourd'hui entre le discours
auquel de plus en plus de personnes
adhèrent et ils ont raison et des
décisions ou des obligations publiques
d'action publique qui sont totalement
contradictoires sache ça
particulièrement dangereux qu'est-ce qui
manque là dedans qui est bien là en
l'occurrence le conseil départemental me
passe mais qu'est ce qui manque là
dedans c'est que pour changer de modèle
il faut pouvoir accompagner et la
réalité c'est que à part s'inquiéter
qu'on voit justement des événements ou
des photos les politiques publiques
derrière elles ne suivent pas donc vous
disiez très justement et donc nous avons
un point de convergence 2-2 2-3 presque
majoritaire sur l'heure du jour mais le
visa exactement mais mais effectivement
il faut il faut aujourd'hui avoir des
vraies stratégies d'accompagnement des
territoires comme il faut être en
capacité et bien de financer puisque le
train dont je parle et on avait le
gouvernement avait dit qu'ils mettraient
les fonds en octobre dernier pour
pouvoir leur ouvrir et à l'heure où je
vous parle il ne fonctionne toujours pas
donc il faut qu'il y ait de
l'investissement public
cd paris qu'on fait des pays comme le
portugal qui ont mis des milliards
d'euros pour pouvoir changer de modèle
économique et c'est ce qu'on attend
aujourd'hui mon peut pas laisser des
élus locaux devoir essayer comme vous le
dites de gagner du temps en permanence
et quand on est au gouvernement ça
serait bien qu'on ne s'étonne pas des
choses mais qu'on agisse karl valentin
là c'était pas un peu facile de
convoquer les conseillers départementaux
à paris c'était très démagogique parce
que franchement une opération d'une
heure trente qui coûte 5000 euros pour
80 mètres cubes de neige que ça provoque
un tel scandale c'est très démagogique
ensuite on parle c'est très démago voilà
donc c'est pas du tout une catastrophe
que les conduire à la décroissance mais
il faut bien sûr se préoccuper de
l'évolution du climat et cd se
préoccuper de notre facture de notre
bilan carbone et de notre facture
énergétique mais c'est bien évidemment
pas ce qu'on veut et d'hélicoptères qui
va arriver et changer la face du monde
sa cécité un mouvement d'ampleur
c'était une pratique courante de toutes
les stations de c'est vrai que c'est la
problématique de l'ensemble des stations
haskell
sur ce sujet mais pour vous appuyez
votre propos le gouvernement avait la
capacité à la kpc de prendre un arrêté
pour interdire ce genre de chose il le
fait pas merci vraiment c'est scandaleux
donc il se saisit d'une image pour comme
il le fait d'ailleurs pour parler
d'écologie pour parler d'écologie sur
des grands prix le président réputé
d'une même sur europa city sur un
hélicoptère à luchon mais pourquoi mais
pourquoi enfin moi je préférerais que
l'on investisse et qu'on change
véritablement les petits public donc je
et comprennent des vraies décisions
isa bison la possibilité d'interdire sa
s'ils le souhaitent cela dit on ne peut
rien prédire
partant de là on peut actuellement
savourer justifié même d'apporter de la
neige à sées en flandre pour satisfaire
les vacanciers et que les vacanciers
aient envie de revenir la fois d'après
et que ça crée que ça continue à nourrir
des emplois texte a donc dans les
ascenseurs ne changerait l'économie
comme on apporte de la neige en
hélicoptère et voilà et magouilles
irrationnel de tous les côtés c'est
d'abord c'est goutte d'eau dans la mer
enfin versé ridicule d'apporter 50
tonnes de neige va à vau surtout quand
il fait 7 degrés sur les pistes et ça
pour quoi
4 heures donc est ce qui est ridicule
c'est d'aller comme ça alors
l'hélicoptère est ridicule les
explications du du conseil départemental
c'est pour les enfants même thème ainsi
que les emplois mais franchement
et puis encore on quand on est en train
de parler de 50 m2
j'y vais pas la station alors moi je
défends personne et je défends pas non
plus le gouvernement je trouve ça
s'arrête en rêve complet du nord est où
là j'ai malgré tout est totalement
irrationnelle c'est même du super
pouvoir sceller dubaï s'est passé mais
il n'y a pas de nuages c'est pas grave
on va en mettre et non en revanche faut
quand même se souvenir qu'il ya encore
enfin il ya quoi les gens font du ski
depuis un siècle que avant la demande
est encore important d'en bas oui mais
s'il a pu nager punaise donc alors si on
fait des hélicos bon bah du coup on en
aura de moins en moins donc peut-être
aussi rester un modèle et non mais bien
sûr les mines et sont obligés secrétaire
d'état louer avance obligé de réagir à
toutes et tous à la générale il ya plein
de sujets en fait l'un des jeunes auprès
de l'osce ici si vous voulez c'est tout
ça la nature est bien faite aux femmes
où l'un et il ya eu des records de
fréquentation dans beaucoup de stations
d'altitude
cet été parce que quand même avec la
schl au même problème comment il faisait
très chaud les gens montent donc non
mais c'est vrai l'été a été très bon
mental alors nathan 710 me dit rien de
choquant c'est il ya là une logique
économique c'est rationnel chardons
bleus à présent il va neiger à noël et
en février pour le ski et faire très
très beau très chaud pour les vacances
d'été le temps sur mesure bon c'est pas
encore gagné à protéger voilà le sud
peut être qu'on laissera le mot de la
fin à romain magisson apprennent aux
enfants à nager au lieu de skier ça ira
plus vite
voilà je vous remercie retrouve très
bientôt pour de nouveaux débats sur
point de vue bonne soirée à tous